they make it their business to mind your
business parking won't be getting any
easier any time soon in Boston where the
city council banned space-saving apps
like haystack with a simple tap I let my
neighbors know where I'm parked and that
i'll be leaving soon and i even get paid
when it's taken because the band was
pre-emptive officials didn't even try to
justify it on public safety grounds the
city has sole authority to regulate
parking on city-owned streets in this
app potentially threatens that authority
a couple months ago a school tried to
ban sunscreen calling it a toxic
substance this month one new york state
senator wants to make sure citizens do
get slaughtered with a protective lotion
but only so long as it's not expired
senator david carlucci pushed forward a
sunscreen expiration label mandate even
though most sunscreen already comes with
expiration dates says Carlucci after
languishing in the Senate for 14 years I
made it a priority to pass this piece of
legislation to ensure families know the
dangers associated with old sunscreen
right because before there was just no
way to know if your sunscreen wasn't
working but this month's top prize goes
to a different New York nanny who wants
to drain more fun out of summer that's
right free rooms eyebrows the new york
parks department has banned boogie
boards those wonderful devices crafted
especially for the broseph's stoked to
rip some gnarly foamies but lacking the
skill to actually serve at an insult to
injury the department classifies boogie
boards as flotation devices on par with
life preservers and water wings some
speculate that the band is a response to
a couple of kids getting swept to sea
while boogie boarding during the middle
of a hurricane but no one knows for sure
the parks department administrator just
said this there's been an increased use
of them and we have to ban them for
people's safety they're popular so they
must be banned uncles only in Ramat
Falls show on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and check back next month for
more examples of busybodies minding your
own business
you